[Music]
in today's eight on your side a recent
survey shows post pandemic millennials
are looking to get rich quick with
cryptocurrency
as opposed to traditional measures like
stocks or real estate
millennials of course were born between
1980 to 2000
despite high levels of education this
generation has experienced slower
economic growth since entering the
workforce than any other generation in
history
they only hold 4.6 percent of our
country's wealth according to data from
the federal reserve
leanna hawkins founder of blackhawk
financial says the rising housing and
rental costs plus student loan debt
certainly contributing to this trend she
says 72 percent of millennials have
started investing in cryptocurrency in
the past six months
the reason again for that is i think
that there's a lot of heavy pressures on
millennials
the jobs and the wages that they might
have expected
going into a certain career field in
college and getting their degree in that
might not be paying off for them quite
yet i mean they've been
through it's very much actually of my
own personal timeline maybe they've
probably graduated somewhere
just before or just after within a few
hours of the financial crisis and the
big mortgage crisis
throughout 2009 2010 and into 2011
before things started getting better
and then now in the last year we've
dealt with the pandemic
cryptocurrency is a form of payment like
bitcoin and dojo coin it's exchanged
online for goods and services involving
technology
some cryptocurrencies can earn you
dividends you can also earn money
through day trading cryptocurrencies but
once a trader purchase is made there's
no going back
hawkins says it's a volatile and risky
way to make money she says you might get
rich quick but she says
it should by no means be the basis of
your portfolio